Okay, the answer, of course, is HTML is rendered by
the browser. Let's go ahead and see that in practice.
When I click add here, pizza gets added very largely
to our shopping list, of course this is probably not what
we intended, and we can even put better HTML in
here. Potatoes, the marquee tag is always fun for this
sort of thing. And as you can see, we have
now totally screwed up our shopping list. Now we discussed this
in the previous lesson. This is because we did not
escape our HTML when we displayed it allowing the user to
enter raw HTML into the page. Now, let's see what,
how this happened in practice. When we actually rendered our list,
we're just sticking the raw HTML directly into the page,
allowing the user to put arbitrary HTML into our page. And
in this particular case, it's somewhat amusing. But if they had
inserted javascript into our page, which, to be fair, modern browsers
don't allow you do it anymore. They could actually do some
really nasty things, like, steal my authentication cookies and send it back
home. Which is a common way of breaking into websites that
I may or may not done a lot of in my youth.